Flash, the old timey sounds that
recall baseball from the '20s
were equal parts
acting and technology.
Hey guys and dolls.
Trace here with the
latest in vocal repartee.
One of my favorite things to
do when I'm doing a fake accent
is an old timey
newsreel announcer.
Just throw on a quick flash
and then use normal sentences.
It sounds way better.
Flash, rebels take
the planet of Endor.
So why did those
guys talk like that?
Firstly, they didn't
actually talk like that.
They announced like that.
And they acted like that.
Around the turn of
the last century,
America was still proving
itself as a nation.
At the time, parts
of the Northeast
and mid-Atlantic regions
had a certain affectation
in their accent.
It was like a blend of
British and American,
but not entirely either.
It came from certain groups
of the American aristocracy
and fell out of favor
after World War II.
It was also taught as a manner
of speech for Hollywood actors.
You might recognize the accent
from someone like Cary Grant.
Well, I imagine you've had wide
acquaintance amongst policemen.
I'll have to call one
if you keep that up.
But when you electronically
record the human voice,
things get even stranger.
It was recently discovered that
French bookseller douard-Lon
Scott de Martinville
was the first to record
the human voice.
In 1857, de Martinville
patented the phonautograph,
a simple device that recorded
the vibration of sound waves
onto soot-covered paper.
That invention
eventually evolved
into Edison's phonograph,
which could actually
play the sounds back.
But it sounded really tinny.
This had to do with
the lack of technology
at the time for capturing bass.
And as recording and
reproduction improved,
the sound got better,
and reproduction, more
and more accurate.
Then we were presented
with a new problem--
we hated the way our
voices sound when
it was recorded, right?
What the hell is that?
In case, you're wondering, yes,
that is what you sound like.
And a higher pitched
version of yourself
is really what it is, with a lot
more [ANNOYING SOUND] in there.
But when you speak,
you can hear yourself.
So why does it sound different?
Your bones.
Sound vibrates everything
around it, including our bones.
So when we speak our voice,
goes out of our mouth,
through the air, and
then into our ears.
But it also goes
through our skull
and resonates into
the backs of our ears,
making our voice sound deeper.
So why do we hate it so much?
Because mirrors lie.
They lie to you,
and you lie to you.
We spend our hives looking
in the mirror perfecting
how we think we look.
But that is not you.
That's a reverse image.
Your left side is you right.
Your right side is your left.
The whole world is upside
down-- well, flipped anyway.
We spend our lives perfecting
the sound of a voice
that only we hear.
So when we hear it
as others do, it's
similar to the one
we know and love.
But it's not quite right.
What is your favorite accent?
British?
Southern?
Jack Sparrow?
Throw your favorites,
and why, in the comments
so we can talk all about it.
Thanks for tuning in
to DNews everybody.
Find us on social media.
We are out there.
I'm Trace.
See you later.